AC might with a wrist shot that goes wide he was
being watched by Schulz back around the boards
chernack gives it up this going to be a breakway
it's going to be a 2 on0 schz in stop rebound
Johanson got him both sends it back in deep for
Everly Everly up there with wiberg back to the
point it goes gun it peeled off with the chains
there a shot and the rebound picked up and blasted
in there rebound they score and it's Brian dban
who finds the back of the Nets and Seattle you can
feel it come and they were pushing and they get
the opening goal of the game was he in deep but
prior to that Johansson had made two really good
saves that was a tough one there because of the
redirection he directed it into the corner another
really good save look where he kicked it he kicked
it into the corner below the circle that's what
the goener is supposed to do but nobody's covered
Brian dumin it went moved so far down below the
circle on that side you don't see that very often
from demen picked up by Jamie Alexia there's the
goal score dlin now down the wing comes Yamamoto
on his back hand and that one is punched down by
Johanson back in the middle for G his shot scores
y gour back in Tampa makes it two nothing crack
SPS so Yamamoto can end up keeping the puck and
go all the way around so now he's coming like a
salmon swimming Upstream here coming the opposite
direction that misdirection a lot of times will
sort of Mesmerize everybody out there let's see
what all the guys in blue were doing yeah they're
all looking there meanwhile Yanni gord's going the
right direction he's going right down the middle
of the ice and the Top Line the point line has
had their moments defensively this season two
goals in 61 seconds and they got the lead here
on the [Applause] road Celli puts it back to
Line This is radish radish works it across to
flurry flurry in front trying to find a tip scor
tapped into the side of the nich by tanor Jano
and he cuts the deficit to one now it's got Jano
on the wing and Marilla and they just get Puck
to the net jeno's in good position here he get it
through and then Jano just creates a little bit of
Separation the puck comes off of grow he doesn't
control the rebound real well but look at flurry
flurry does a real nice job and it was actually
Jano that caused the bad rebound that was a shot
pass from flurry Jano gets a stick on it so the
golender has to just kick it out overall they are
94.7% and a second in the NHL here's Ben and
shoots save by Johansson kicks that one out
right to chernack and he lobs this one back
down the ice that was benus going laterally
along the Blue Line there got in behind chernack
that was a good scoring chance and a great quick
up Schwarz drops it off Yamamoto carries it in
and Seattle sets things up here's dun dun shot
and then it's tipped wide of the lightning net
veneers back to the point for Vince dun Down the
Cross onetime stop rebound scores and it is
Yamamoto with a power play goal and Seattle
has found some offense here in this first period
tonight in Tampa Bay yeah lightning is sloppy in
front of him but for sure fabulous saves here
and he makes another big one this the second
timer rebound after a great save that's a great
save on the stick side he keeps that one out on
that one timer watch this that's a bullet but he
doesn't get enough support in front of the net
turnac gets there but they have two guys it's a
one-w punch yamamoto's farther out the puck just
kind of sits there for a minute it was almost a an
accidental pass by Schwarz to Yamamoto turned out
perfectly but you can't fault the goal tender of
tell you just beloved by their teammates too both
Belmar and Yanni gourd it's been a couple years
for gourd but still when you win cups with guys
and go through it it it never leaves you you're
you're friends for life but just now for the next
40 minutes join a very elite group of players with
200 career Power Play Goals more Mor join that
club one minute remaining in this lightning power
play second unit on this with shot loose po there
for Rebound than score Alex bar ble pounds it
home and it's 32 had been taken away and it
was Pier Belmar in the slot going to take away
this onetime right there good stick movement but
Tanner Jano who's been in the right place more
often than anybody else in a blue jersey so far
in this game keeps this Play Alive he jams away
at it and because of that he gets some health
I think it was perfect smooth down there and
then Bari Boule on the back side as that puck
just filtered through a couple of skates and
sticks and Bari ble is in the right place to
put that one in dumped in here's bmar in the
corner stripped back to the line serach shoots
rebound is cleared by Seattle wow serip had a
real clean look at the neck here's a slap shot
that just missed out in frzy and big blocker saved
by Johanson on y strength I'm telling you he look
out and he fires that one wide that was borren
again sorry Brian and the lightning going get
a chance to get this one out and then up up the
ice Hegel in backand all the way in there stop by
Kau lightning realize that they got to step on the
gas here keep pounding them and taking it to them
there make them feel as tired as they can so here
we go third period underway 3-2 Seattle puts it up
on to the tape there of bar ble here's Sherry and
sto by Kow what a chance for Connor Sherry flurry
with a lead pass up ahead to Bar Boule bar Boule
curls back to the line flurry with a shot that
caught the post and ricochets out of play that
pass off the stick a kov into the Zone up of
the play point to COV and shoots and he fired it
high headman up ahead to Bar ble Cuts back hangs
on puts it into the corner for Celli pass got
through him but it's picked up now by Hegel back
in front desar Brandon Hegel puts it towards the
net and it gets in [Music] somehow and it's a tie
game in the back of the net when other guys
have it hegel's always on the puck retrieves
it in behind that went off of foot I thought
it went off of Celli's foot I guess Hegel went
to the bench first who does this go but it's a
nasty redirection there went between the feet
of Celli but I think that went off of Vince
dun initially right here there's the change
of Direction serach walk L snap shot just
missed rebound here cour WS shoots oh the
rebound just got away from stos and both
teams are going to take one point from
this one and we're going to go to three on
three overtime to see see who gets the extra
point he sends out Luke lenning to win the
face off because that's been part of the
problem this season they've lost the opening
draw and never got the puck back they've been
out shot 7 nothing in the two overtime games
they've been in this season well Coupe said
the other day after the loss he said well I
got to either start figuring out what we're
going to do when we're out there or who
goes out here's Yanni going rebound big
save Again by Johanson on yanny gour makes
his time being watched by chernack here's
Bor strand near side mccan he's at a sharp
angle walks it out all the way up top to
bortan Across The Dun McAn shoots and scores
buries it and Seattle wins it everything was
set up for McAn the 40 goal scorer of last
year he's got four goals coming into this one